[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils avaient Tsumi vous êtes né de père
camerounais de mère française
ce sont vos passeurs de vie métisse
comme dirait David Diop c'est une
magnifique expression comment vit-on une
double culture
écoutez c'est une vraie chance d'avoir
une double culture il faut juste savoir
l'appréhender c'est vrai que ce n'est
pas simple je me souviens quand j'étais
enfant au Cameroun on me Hellé dans la
rue en m'appelant ça veut dire la
blanche en néwondo la langue de mon père
et quand je passais l'été dans la ferme
de ma grand-mère dans le Tarn et que
j'allais à la messe le dimanche les
dames me caressaient les cheveux en
disant les frissés comme un mouton donc
voilà on vit avec ça et mais pour avoir
prendre une expression familière quand
on me dit que les Métis sont le cul
entre deux chaises parce que je réponds
c'est oui on a deux chaises et donc ça
c'est une vraie chance parce que on
apprend la capacité d'adaptation qui est
un viatique pour toute la vie ça
important mais il y a pas quand même une
quête d'identité parce que vous avez
écrit un livre qui s'appelle Bamako
climax que je recommande d'ailleurs très
beau livre dans lequel il y a trois
personnages principaux et il y en a un
garçon qui est africain justement il y a
un autre garçon qui est juif ils sont
amoureux d'une femme et on a
l'impression que ce roman c'est quand
même une quête de leurs origines
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous avez
voulu dire là justement qui a quand même
une quête d'identité à chaque fois bien
sûr mais il y a une quête d'identité
pour pour tout être humain effectivement
le personnage que je mets en scène qui a
ce personnage masculin qui est noir et
qui toute sa vie à essayer de masquer
cette négritude pour essayer de
s'insérer dans dans la société française
notamment et donc c'est aussi un livre
qui parle du plafond de verre de dans la
société française qu'il faut apprendre à
dépasser
oui c'est encore le cas quand on prend
certains secteurs
par exemple on prend le monde de
l'entreprise les grandes entreprises du
CAC 40 j'ai rejoint une de ces
entreprises oranges il y a nous ne
sommes que trois membres de comités
exécutifs du CAC 40 d'origine africaine
sur plus de 600 donc quand même question
alors vous avez employé un mot qui est
intéressant négritude
qui est un mot qui est né dans la bouche
de Aimé Césaire de Léopold Sédar Senghor
c'est un mot qui pour vous et un mot qui
est une affirmation
identitaire justement ou au contraire
c'est un mot à rejeter complètement
comme le disent aujourd'hui beaucoup de
jeunes finalement qui ce mot on n'aime
pas parce qu'il écorche ça caractère un
peu raciste même
oui certains moi je j'aime la langue
française comme vous savez et donc je ne
m'arrête pas au connotation je ne fais
pas partie des personnes qui veulent
rebaptiser 10 petits d'Agatha
Christie
culture absolument pas la négritude
c'est d'abord un mouvement politique
aussi donc c'est d'abord c'est pas là
c'est un gorge c'est ses airs c'est
c'est la poésie et pour moi c'est c'est
le contraire de l'enfermement pour moi
c'est une affirmation universaliste la
négritude pour moi c'est comment voilà
les noirs qui ont dans l'histoire a
souvent été gommée tronqué
reprennent la place qui mérite dans le
grand concert international et c'est
aussi voilà c'est tout l'histoire de de
cet Afrique on enseigne pas suffisamment
dans notre pays et des histoires
fatinantes de grandeur parce que si on
l'a transmet pas correctement on
hérite d'une vision avec tous les
clichés donc moi par exemple je raconte
avec bonheur à mes enfants l'histoire
d'Aboubacar 3 empereur du Mali qui un
jour en 1300 et quelques décident
d'aller voir ce qu'il y a de l'autre
côté de la mer à fret une flotte de
bateau qui
dont on ne sait pas ce qu'ils sont
devenus mais certains historiens pensent
que Aboubakar 3 a découvert l'Amérique
avant Christophe Colomb parce que
certains mots par exemple Niagara en
bambara ça veut dire l'eau vive il y a
un certain nombre de correspondances les
poteries qu'on a retrouvé aussi de
l'époque donc voilà toute cette histoire
fascinante de la grandeur de l'Afrique
c'est important de la transmettre pour
casser les clichés oui alors en plus ce
qui est intéressant
dans votre parcours c'est que vous vous
êtes issu d'un pays qui est assez
particulier en Afrique qui s'appelle le
Cameroun donc et qui est un pays qui a
été traversé par des colonisations très
différentes on le voit là ce pays
d'Afrique centrale
qui donne sur le golf Guinée qui a deux
grandes villes qui s'appelle Yaoundé et
Douala avec une triple influence
extérieure qui a été l'influence
germanophone d'abord qu'on a un peu
oublié une influence après après la
guerre de 14 qui a été à la fois
anglophone et francophone puisque le
Cameroun qui était d'abord sous
influence allemande a été redistribué il
y a donc une pays est coupé en fait le
Nord est un peu germanophone encore
et puis l'est et plutôt francophone et
l'Ouest anglophone je me trompe pas
c'est un peu ça en fait les Camerounais
sont un peuple très fier
pourquoi parce que techniquement nous
n'avons jamais été colonisé puisque le
Cameroun a d'abord été un état allemand
cameronstad après la répartition de la
Conférence de Berlin ensuite première
salle voilà ensuite Première Guerre
mondiale les Allemands perdent il y a eu
des batailles décisives d'ailleurs au
Cameroun et donc le Cameroun passe sous
mandat de la Société des Nations avec
une partie effectivement
gérée par administré par les
Britanniques l'autre par les Français
c'est important de le préciser et
effectivement c'est un pays très
particulier parce que le aujourd'hui il
y a une partie anglophone qui est près
de ligne Nigéria une partie francophone
et puis le Nord qui est c'est aussi un
une mosaïque religieuse avec un or qui
est musulman et
un Sud voilà un Sud qui est chrétien
donc catholique protestant tout le monde
étant plus ou moins animistes toujours
l'animisme est toujours très très 13 ans
et effectivement on dit aussi que c'est
l'Afrique en miniature c'est c'est un
creuset de de culture enfin voilà je
vais pas faire une diatribe patriote
mais c'est un pays en plus qui a qui qui
peut être amené à avoir une place de
pivot dans l'Afrique centrale dans toute
cette redistribution des cartes que l'on
voit toutes ces influences qu'il y a qui
s'agitent sur le continent je pense que
ce pays a beaucoup d'atouts pour pour
être un pays amateurs de l'Afrique alors
justement
1960 la période des indépendances avec
un homme en France qui a eu son heure de
gloire après 74 allée des jours
présidentielles qui s'appelait René
Dumont
première écologiste de l'histoire
française peut-être il y en a eu
d'autres avant lui et qui a écrit un
livre l'Afrique noire est mal parti il
parlait notamment de l'Afrique
agricole
60 ans après les indépendances 2023 quel
bilan tirez-vous de cette
de cette décolonisation et de cette
affirmation nationale de chacun des pays
africains
c'est vrai que par certains aspects
René Dumont avait raison l'Afrique est
mal parti mais pourquoi parce que
finalement ces indépendances ont été
complètement confisquées
tous les leaders
des indépendances des mouvements de
colonisation qui souvent étaient des
panafricanistes convaincus en Afrique à
l'époque c'était la volonté de vivre
tous ensemble enfin de de d'avoir un
objectif commun et de faire de l'Afrique
globalement une force absolument et
c'est pas la revendication
identitaire d'aujourd'hui c'était
vraiment faire
une force et justement
c'est assez indépendants ont été
confisquées parce que les anciens
colonisateurs ont choisi la stratagème
classique divisée
donc voilà le rêve des indépendants
c'est assez vite brisé avec toutefois
des destins disparate selon les
différences selon selon les pays mais
aujourd'hui je suis une une optimiste
une afro optimiste convaincue parce que
parce que je pense que finalement en
Afrique se joue aujourd'hui
le sort de du basculement de nos
sociétés tout entière c'est-à-dire qu'en
Afrique pour moi l'Afrique est à la fois
une terre de résilience et d'innovation
alors voilà une terre de résilience
parce que effectivement
l'histoire meurtrie qui commence avec la
saigner de l'esclavagisme voilà ces
indépendances et à la colonisation le
pillage des ressources etc et malgré
tout ce continent a énormément avancé
une classe moyenne qui est là
aujourd'hui une croissance
portée justement par l'innovation
technologique le numérique etc donc une
résilience et puis cette innovation
parce que finalement c'est le continent
des sauts de grenouilles si je prends
l'exemple d'un domaine que je connais un
petit peu la téléphonie on c'est on a
l'Afrique vous travaillez chez Orange
donc l'Afrique n'a pas connu le
téléphone fixe on est passé directement
au téléphone mobile avec tout le
potentiel de croissance que la connexion
amen
le paiement par téléphone mobile c'est
en Afrique qui l'a vraiment qui s'est
vraiment généralisé le Mobile Money en
Afrique existe depuis 15 ans depuis et
donc soutient le développement de petite
entreprise le mobile est aussi venu
pallier le faible taux de bancarisation
du continent donc voilà on est vraiment
dans une accélération
très forte de l'histoire et du et du de
capacité de développement d'un continent
d'où la l'appétit je dirais des autres
continents et des de toutes les grandes
puissances dans le monde qui boire en
Afrique peut-être une espèce d'Eldorado
pour l'avenir avec les Terrass avec une
démographie importante avec une
inventivité une jeunesse elle a un rôle
capital à jouer géostratégiquement
l'Afrique évidemment elle a un rôle
capital parce que pour
c'est aussi une un nouveau marché les
potentiel est énorme et encore une fois
résilience d'individus en 2050
absolument et donc encore une fois
résilience innovation je prends un autre
exemple taux d'électrification du
continent 46% seulement donc l'avantage
c'est que le continent s'électrifie de
manière verte nativement et par exemple
orange est un opérateur téléphonique
mais on a aussi lancé des services
d'énergie où on propose des kit solaire
dans les foyers qui n'ont pas
l'électricité avec les possibilités de
payer la facture par mobile etc donc
voilà avec très vite grâce à cette
capacité d'innovation à la fois on
répond à des objectifs environnementaux
la solarisation sociétaux parce que
l'électricité dans un foyer ça change la
vie c'est un gamin qui n'a plus à
étudier sous la lampe tempête c'est la
connectivité il peut trouver des
ressources pédagogiques se former c'est
développer des activités génératrices de
revenus aussi qui sont en lien avec les
électricité donc avant sans électricité
c'est comme si la vie s'arrête à la
tombée de la nuit la moitié de la moitié
d'une vie la nécessité c'est voilà donc
et tout ça voilà encore une fois
résilience innovation et alors on parle
depuis le début là de l'Afrique mais il
y a pas l'Afrique c'est il y a des
Afrique où vous êtes d'Afrique centrale
du Cameroun on l'a dit pour rester dans
le domaine Francophone
l'Afrique centrale ça n'a rien à voir
avec l'Afrique de l'Ouest
toute façon chaque pays est unique donc
effectivement il y a quand même des il y
a des cousinages si on prend une musique
qui irrigue aujourd'hui la
quasi-totalité du continent ce serait
voilà la rumba congolaise les musiques
nigériennes aussi donc il y a quand même
des facteurs de unificateur
mais après effectivement
le il y a peu de rapport entre le
Botswana et le digère les les PIB sont
très différents et c'est aussi ce qui
fait voilà tout l'intérêt de ce
continent alors il y a une chose qui est
assez intéressante de constater
aujourd'hui c'est que une espèce de
révolte dans la jeunesse africaine et
c'est assez assez visible notamment dans
toute l'Afrique francophone de l'Ouest
centrale avec un ressentiment quand même
vis-à-vis de la France
et vis-à-vis de l'Occident
et là c'est un autre panafricanisme
c'est d'un panafricanisme identitaire
qui est assez agressif d'ailleurs par
certains aspects comment vous voyez vous
cette rupture qui peut exister pas
partout pas dans toute la jeunesse mais
dans une partie de cette jeunesse qui
demande des comptes aujourd'hui
moi je distinguerai de deux points je
pense que
par certains aspects parfois la Colère
vient tout simplement
de la difficulté de se projeter dans
l'avenir avec une jeunesse qui a un taux
de chômage très élevé certains pays et
donc ça on peut y répondre la bonne
nouvelle c'est que c'est qu'on peut y
répondre en accompagnant massivement les
jeunes dans le développement de
compétences clés dans les métiers
d'avenir et le numérique en ayant on
estime que pour soutenir sa croissance
l'Afrique va avoir besoin de 230
millions d'emplois liés au numérique
donc oui 230 millions à horizon 2030
donc l'enjeu est immense donc pour une
population grosso modo en 2030 qui sera
d'un million d'un milliard 500 000 500
millions d'individus après
effectivement
il peut y avoir des explications à cette
à cette colère les explications
historiques et puis aussi peut-être
aussi cette politique migratoire moi je
quand je vois la génération de de mon
père par exemple qui a pu bénéficier de
bourse pour faire pour pouvoir venir
faire des études en France ce sont des
générations qui ont formé les élites
locales de retour au pays après les
indépendances et qui vont profondément
francophiles or aujourd'hui on sait
qu'il y a beaucoup plus précisé votre
père il était il est issu d'un milieu
rural plutôt paysan et il s'est élevé il
a fait Léna il est devenu diplomate il
est devenu même ambassadeur du Cameroun
à Washington aux États-Unis voilà de
l'école de missionnaire où il allait à
pied donc au Cameroun jusque jusqu'à
Léna
à Paris à l'époque et donc aujourd'hui
il y a un sujet de politique migratoire
on accorde de moins en moins de visa aux
étudiants africains
et résultats ils vont faire leurs études
ailleurs en Allemagne au Canada
dans d'autres pays d'Afrique le leur et
forcément c'est une génération qui qui
qui perd le lien avec la France mais il
y a aussi une volonté de dire on n'est
plus dans la situation de coloniser on
veut un partenariat qui soit différent
oui oui alors effectivement un
partenariat différent alors une partie
de la jeunesse d'ailleurs maintenant
beaucoup plus aux États-Unis enfin le
calcul plus la France comme dans
certains pays francophones c'est une
réalité et après mais effectivement ce
partenariat et c'est et c'est là où les
diaspora à mon sens sont un rôle clé je
pense que le pour redéfinir ce
partenariat et les la France intérêt à
s'appuyer sur sur sa diaspora africaine
et à la valoriser à la mettre en avant
je suis convaincu que la plus notre pays
mettra en avance à diversité plus il
sera attractif à l'international
alors il y a la place des femmes en
Afrique dont on parle assez peu
d'ailleurs
elles ont une place capitale
dans la cellule familiale c'est souvent
la femme qui gouverne non
sous forme de matriarcat ce sont les
femmes qui portent ce continent
ça c'est une réalité
qui se mesure d'ailleurs alors déjà
c'est le premier contre l'Afrique est le
premier continent de l'entrepreneuriat
féminin 25% de femmes plus il y a plus
d'entrepreneurs femmes en Afrique que
qu'en Europe
dans le monde et
pourquoi
tout les programmes de développement
doivent s'appuyer sur les femmes c'est
parce que dès qu'on accompagne les
femmes vers l'autonomie financière
notamment avec le microcrédit ça
bénéficie de facto à tout le foyer par
exemple pourquoi les organismes de
micro-crédit préfèrent octroyer des
microcrédits aux femmes parce qu'elles
sont elles rembourse plus que que les
hommes et puis sur il y a des exemples
formidables aussi si je prends le
Liberia la guerre
terrible depuis ce sont les lieux des
années 90 qui était là les premiers
victimes à un moment on dit stop elle se
sont regroupées en mouvement de paix les
prises voilà elles se sont mobilisées et
donc ça a donné d'ailleurs une
présidente
Johnson qui a été la première présidente
d'un pays africain et qui a fait deux
mandats d'ailleurs c'est exactement le
l'illustration de ce bouddhiste mais il
y en a pas beaucoup quand même de femmes
en politique encore on a malheureusement
les deux extrêmes à cause de cela on a
des femmes qui sont encore victimes de
mutilation sexuelle avec l'excision qui
est un drame centrale notamment
en Afrique centrale un peu un petit peu
moins et à côté de ça on a des pays par
exemple l'assemblée la plus paritaire au
monde le Rwanda
plus fort taux de femmes au Parlement
dans le monde soit le Rwanda donc à côté
de ça on a aussi de très beaux exemples
alors le Rwanda qui est souvent montré
en exemple aujourd'hui après la tragédie
qu'il a vécu en 1994 avec le génocide
le Rwanda qui a une croissance
économique absolument extraordinaire le
Rwanda qui est montré en modèle comme
une Suisse en Afrique aujourd'hui mais
le Rwanda qui est quand même dans un
régime assez autoritaire est-ce que on
peut concilier croissance économique
développement et démocratie
moi je ne fais pas partie
de ceux qui prétendent qu'il faudrait un
régime différent pour l'Afrique sous
prétexte que c'est ce sont des histoires
particulières la démocratie a montré a
fait ses preuves à peu près partout dans
le monde parce que sont quand même des
valeurs avec c'est la liberté c'est
l'égalité c'est
donc voilà je pense que le la démocratie
est une condition importante je pense
après voilà qui a des sujets de
gouvernance dans certains pays qu'il
faut clairement régler
mais je pense qu'arrive aujourd'hui une
génération de jeunes
qui vont pas se laisser faire qui vont
revendiquer qui vont voilà qui
aujourd'hui armés en termes d'éducation
qui sont biberonnés aux images
extérieures
envers envers leur régime et voilà je
pense que les la société je crois
beaucoup à la force de la société civile
sur le continent de plus en plus
et bien se faire entendre finalement
dans tous les pays africains alors si
vous voulez bien vous prêter à une
espèce de questionnaire de Proust si je
vous dis quel est votre
créatrice de mode ou créateur de mode
préféré africain s'il y en a plein il y
en a énormément c'est un des domaines
dans lequel l'Afrique se rayonne un peu
partout dans le monde maintenant alors
mon créateur préférerait est un grand
frère un ami un grand frère Iman Haïti
qui dont je suis très fière parce qu'il
est le premier créateur d'Afrique
subsaharienne à avoir intégré il y a
deux ans maintenant la la très
prestigieuse chambre syndicale de la
haute couture française il est au
calendrier des défilés haute couture
c'est une grande fierté parce que je
l'ai vu c'est un ami d'AD olescence et
je l'ai vu persévérer dans cette voie
qui n'était pas simple et arrivé au
firmament de la de la haute couture
française un écrivain quel est
l'écrivain qui
l'écrivain africain qui a vos faveurs
alors beaucoup encore c'est très
difficile de choisir mais je dirais à
shimam Gozzi addicier et qui viennent
nigériane qui a publié ce best-seller
américain
à la fin et qui résume dans son œuvre à
la fois ces problématiques et
identitaires des diaspora à la fois se
bouillonnement le gouvernement de ce
grand pays qui est le Nigéria qui est le
pays le plus peuplé d'Afrique avec avec
un pays complètement schizophrène avec
avec des milliardaires et une classe
voilà peur classe
moyenne très forte et en même temps
voilà encore de la misère aussi des
voilà des des tiraillements liés à la
religion aussi avec des musulmans et le
sudisme qui sévit avec beaucoup arabes
elle a un talent fou pour
pour raconter cette fresque et ce
continuum finalement qui qui l'Afrique
n'est pas incontinent à part l'Afrique
et partout exactement et ce Americana
donc ce livre on le trouve aussi en
langue française il est traduit
alors un plat c'est un parce que c'est
un plat extrêmement raffiné ça se passe
c'est le nanguin c'est à dire gâteau de
pistache c'est un plat de fête des
graines de courges qu'on écrase
qui forme une terrine qu'on fait cuire
dans des feuilles de bananier et qu'on
peut farcir avec de la viande du poisson
ou pour les les plus courageux par-ci de
verre de palmiste donc quand on les
achète au marché c'est dans des bassines
ça grouille c'est pas du tout envie mais
c'est exquis fondant et très protéiné et
vous vous le cuisinez vous même alors
c'est trop compliqué pour moi il faut il
faut tourner et là je défends le loisir
de cuisiner pendant une journée mais je
sais cuisiner d'autres plaques à mon nez
le café la sauce
le Dombas donc en cuisine quelques-uns
quand même et alors la musique ah la
musique la musique si j'étais chauvine
je dirais évidemment le makossa
donc popularisé dans le monde entier par
par regretter Manu Dibango
mais d'abord il y a pas très longtemps
malheureusement du covid absolument et
d'ailleurs
je raconte une anecdote parce que j'ai
il s'est littéralement penché sur mon
mon berceau parce que je suis né au
moment où sol makossa sort aux
États-Unis et que l'Amérique découvre et
donc il était en tournée et de passage
dans la résidence de mes parents donc et
c'était le pour vous dire le phénomène
il a fait la il était tête d'affiche de
l'Apollo Theater le
[Musique]
de l'époque était très jaloux parce
qu'au départ il devait faire la première
partie des Temptations et ça s'est
transformé
d'accord voilà évidemment le makoza mais
j'aime beaucoup aussi la rumba
congolaise qui est parce que c'est une
musique très métisse c'est une musique
qui a été inspirée de la rumba cubaine
mais voilà assaisonné à la sauce
congolaise et cette musique qui a qui a
accompagné les indépendances notamment
le célèbre indépendance Chacha
voilà
un grand chanteur congolais que j'ai vu
d'ailleurs moi-même en concert qui
s'appelle Franco évidemment que vous
connaissez sans doute et
voilà Franco c'est Mario
alors Franco malheureusement est mort du
sida dans les années 90 au début des
années 90 c'était un magnifique chanteur
je confirme
[Musique]
merci beaucoup